a MasterCard is actually a pretty good
in case history because when leap it was
a new business pitch there were six
agencies who were going after this
business and we were all given the same
brief all we were we were told to use
their existing end line which is kind of
what I guess you would call slogan which
is was it that the future of money and
it was all over the world everywhere you
went you saw a MasterCard the future of
money nobody remembered it but it was
all over the world and so all six
agencies tried to execute against that
positioning line and we were the only
ones that did not do that because we we
couldn't we couldn't get any resonance
with the consumer with that line it was
pushing us in the direction of the
futuristic non you know electronic money
it wasn't really a very warm and
friendly place to be and so one day one
creative person came up with a line
there are some things money can't buy
for everything else there's MasterCard
and another creative person came up with
the priceless campaign that was Joyce
king Thomas who has been watching that
campaign for the last 10 years not just
in America but all around the world and
the way we got to that was a very long
process we had a very good strategy that
said you know people who think of
themselves as good revolvers people who
use their credit card for the four good
reasons and that's everybody it's the
other guy who is not doing it for good
reasons you know they thought that they
were buying things that were worthwhile
and from that we got to the difference
between a MasterCard user and other
credit card users and they were buying
things because it was good for the
family and that back little insight
there really triggered the entire
process but you still needed a creative
person to come up with the priceless
idea and a creative person like this
creative director Joyce king Thomas to
make sure that it didn't get stale that
it's still exciting and you and if you
have a client like the MasterCard client
who stays with you on this then you can
have a long-term marketing approach that
is quite
it's in textbooks i mean the mastercard
case is in textbooks from my nephew's go
to school and they see it oh my god you
know that's the only thing they really
respect me for is that Wow mastercards
in my textbook so it's pretty exciting
you